mesh welcome to simulation
thank you atlas thank you for having me
here
super pumped for our show together
i really appreciated mesha's presence in
the no limit society a lot
thank you
mesh does a really good job at holding
space
and that is a skill that is emerging
more and more as highly
sought after by
people that are experiencing awakening
and the more pure the space holder
the more they are of a navy seal
spiritual navy seal
the more
out of the way they are
of their conditioning and they're just
holding the space from
a place of pure service to
the creation awakening so
mesh has definitely been doing that
quite a bit and i've really enjoyed that
so i'm pumped pumped to share this with
you all
we're gonna go ahead i'm sorry i uh i
was gonna say the first because
i don't think you were on the first two
calls we had i was not
and it was really nice to see your
presence and
i think i dropped in halfway through one
of your guided meditations
for a little bit and it was beautiful it
was just beautiful
to see you know someone come up and
provide a
provide more structure provide space for
everyone
because as you know we're all uh it's
the beginning of a new program and
uh we're co-creating it together so it's
beautiful when people
step up and put in a piece of themselves
thank you
yeah you were there the month
prior to when i got involved and
getting involved is so interesting
because
the first question to ask is where are
you
coming from when you're getting involved
and so now i'm undergoing this process
of
really purifying where i'm coming from
so that it's not coming from the
atlas needing to be seen which i found
out as
a pretty interesting core weakness
and versus coming from a pure place of
service
perpetually and so that's been
really interesting but like you said
there's also the
pure spontaneity that does arise where
it's
truly like beautiful just arising out of
emptiness this
this guiding the more
talking conversation into something
that's just a little bit more let's ease
into the perfection that we already
are for a little bit and
it's been really nice sort of also just
getting reflected from all of you which
are already really advanced level
awakened beings
the things that i get to work on myself
and that's been really important yeah
that question
where am i coming from it's so big
it's so big it's all these um
when you really dig into that you start
to see these layers of your
personality emerging and then
also falling apart which is
which is beautiful because
from about two months ago
at least two to three months ago i was
or i should say mesh was
a very different very different person
just so much need for validation and
this desire to be seen
and
okay we you gotta take us into this
story we'll we'll talk about some of the
other stuff on the journey of awakening
but
take us right into this this is like the
heat of it
the transition in the last couple of
months from the need to be
seen to more not that
yeah so
i didn't even realize there was a desire
to be seen it was
so far hidden in
the psyche and it was it had expression
but it was not to my knowledge
and how it came
to my awareness was a few years ago i
had a
i developed an autoimmune condition
called myasthenia gravis
and i joined
bentino's no limits mentorship program
and one of the first questions of mine
was about healing
and his answer had to do with
how
a lot of these illnesses come up
for one of two reasons both kind of
coming from the same reason but it's
either
it's a catalyst to
bring to awareness what your overall
blueprint came here to learn
or there is some sort of karmic
propensity for it so if you
understand what
the catalyst is trying to show you the
symptoms and the illness will subside
so it was because of this i had a deep
dive into
all these different aspects of my psyche
and a lot of my desire to be seen
came just from my upbringing and
this had nothing to do with my parents
were amazing amazing parents loved me to
death
um the family i grew up in was very
supportive
however what you're told and what you
see
as a child is two very different things
so you're told by your parents we love
you you know we're here for you
however just from cultural condition or
cultural background like
as we said before i'm from sri lanka and
a lot of it um you know there's so much
pressure
to do to do well in school and there's
so much pressure
to do well in everything it's just
coming from a poor country it's you know
education is the way out into happiness
it's a success
in our in the version of success
of what we call it and um
you know i come i come home with like
all a's and a b and it's like
where did that b come from or you know
you get 90
93 94 on the test it's like what
happened to the other seven percent
and it's again it's coming my parents
are coming from a place where they just
want me to excel
but for me it's just oh i'm thinking i
got 93
and it's not acknowledged
and all this you know so there was this
crazy desire to
want to be seen by my parents in such a
way
that i became
i became insanely
focused on proving myself in whichever
way
i could i used to go to the gym six to
seven days a week
and twice a day sometimes i wanted to
get really big and strong
same thing with career self-help courses
everything it was just trying to be a
perfectionist
trying to it was it was this uh
just this little kid who wanted to be
seen
and um
once that came to light everything
changed
it was it was this child
who was who was
acting for it was it was
trying to please the child all my
actions came from trying to please the
child
everything everything
like um i'm in music and even
the music it was like the thing to be
seen if i make it in music
if i have all this love from all these
people this desire to be great
it was all just this little this little
kid's
desire to be seen so in the last few
months all of that came to light and
as you know i read you that uh my shadow
work
and that was the beginning of this huge
transformation where i realized none of
that was me
none of that was me it was all
just
black belief it was all
just things i associated with and uh
yeah that was the beginning of like a
very
big shift into where um
i'm sitting now
i would like to take a
moment to
really hone in on how
much courage
it takes to be so radically
transparently honest
with oneself and mesh is doing a great
job at
sharing with us what it's like
to be this
radically honest transparent energy
in service to
not saying look at what i found out
and praise me but doing it from a place
of
look at the nuanced subtlety
that was hidden so deeply that takes
a good amount of investigation and true
honest
receptivity to reflections to be able to
identify
because i'm going through some similar
stuff right now
and man
it's really this whole idea of a
perpetual self-purification engine
man it feels like we're still at like
stage one of some purification stuff
right now
[Laughter]
this whole child thing is so interesting
because we are familiar with like the
need to be seen because that happens as
an adult a lot
because you're trying to do something
specifically to get the attention of
other people and you can
sort of decipher that if you gain even a
little bit of subtlety you can really
begin to get at that but this one is
a little bit more nuanced because you in
a sense you have to dig
deeper into a history of
your life trajectory and for me very
similar
thing with armenian family lineage
and very similar like you know we got
your ass to the united states so go do
some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what is this consciousness nonsense so
it doesn't pay any bills what the [ __ ]
is this
it's funny i mean my parents
were traditional buddhists
so there was some level of that in my
life
however even growing up
learning buddhism
something seemed off some that the type
of traditional buddhism that is being
taught
in temples it's not complete
i think there was a sense of that even
from even as a young kid i'd be going to
temple and
my my dad would give me a couple of
dollars and he'd say go
put this in the donation bin i'd say oh
okay why do we why do we do this and he
said because it's
good karma and to me
immediately that seemed like if you're
doing it
to get good karma
doesn't the intention seem wrong off the
path
and yeah and even i mean
i don't know what it was just something
there were parts which resonated
and there were parts which didn't
resonate
and
however i think it did set the stage it
definitely set the stage
for me to be
open and receptive at a later
age to when the real kind of path
came came on my doorstep yes
yes sri aurobindo and the mother mere
al-fasa have a great way
of putting it which is that a lot of the
fundamental religions
they act as a stepping stone
to spirituality and
specifically if you get to the mystic
traditions within the religions
like for buddhism you get to
dzogchen and zen
and you have advice vedanta
and sufi metaphysics and gnosticism and
a bunch of these
scattered across kabbalah and they'll
drive you more towards the direct union
with the kingdom of god within you
and so that's a little bit more clear
but there's still this sort of in a
sense like what bentino
is doing which is taking this very
synthesis
driven perspective it's like a meta
pattern
i've i've been on a similar trek the
last couple of years with doing that
and it also merges the self-realization
side of the coin with the
self-actualization
side of the coin which is basically what
like tony robbins and jordan peterson
gary vaynerchuk
do as well uh on the self-actualization
side and marry that with the
self-realization side and
and that's why right now this sort of
modern
way of
sharing the nature is
more resonant and that's why it feels
like we're gravitating
towards this yeah
i agree yeah yeah
cool so let's explore
a a bit of
the trajectory you've already shared
with us but give us
sort of like a pivotal turning point of
like
okay it's inward the job is
in and when like that clicked and then
sort of when um me if you would like to
share some of these like
you know like pop moments like becoming
aware of awareness or
whatnot and becoming aware of being the
creator
and
leading up to nls
sure
[Music]
so like i said from a young age i did
have
a kind of inclination
towards buddhism karma
rebirth these all resonated
very strongly with me meditation
these kind of tools resonated strongly
with me but there was
like i said there wasn't something that
grabbed me
then i went into high school and i
started doing sciences
and i did a full 180 and became
a complete atheist complete complete
absolute atheist and uh
for me it was like yeah it's science and
that's it there's nothing else
and if you can't prove it it doesn't
exist
and it seems like another world now
but that's where i was and
yeah it was like atheistic like
stereotype
almost you know to the point where you
know someone mentioned god i'm like
you don't know what you're talking about
things along those lines and then um
halfway through for my first year of
university my mom
gave me the power of now by eckhart
tolle
and i read about two chapters and i was
like
what is this crap i
like basically put the book down and i
said he said like there was just so much
in there that made no sense to me
and then maybe a year later my mom gave
me the new earth by ekartoli and she
said please just read this book
and she said it's a little easier to get
through than the power of now
and that was life-changing that was it
that was the moment
and i was like all of this makes sense
all of this makes so much sense where he
talks about the pain bodies
being present how time is man-made
there was just so much in that
it was a life-changing experience
and then from that point i was just so
hungry i read the power of now after
that
and alan watts became a huge part of
my listenings all the time
i don't remember how i stumbled upon
bentino
but had found a couple of his videos i
want to say it started with empowerment
with his empowerment series on youtube
from trinfinity
and that really grabbed me because
creating who doesn't want to attract
things into your life right
who doesn't want to create your own
reality
and that's what really got me into the
empowerment side but even now looking at
that
it seems like a different life it seems
like
even that was coming from ego even that
was coming from i want
to create money and create this and that
and um where i got hooked
hooked on bentino was his uh
during the pandemic he did the free
retreat the world
that that was one of the
clearest paths to enlightenment
self-realization that
anyone has ever laid out hands down
yeah it was amazing just the description
of the bodies
and it was a path it was an actual path
it wasn't meditate for 500 000 lifetimes
you know and something could happen and
he said no it's possible now
it's possible in this lifetime yes
that was that was the big uh
big shift for me towards bentini's work
i wouldn't say i have any crazy pop
out experiences in this sense of
i truly felt oneness god
i wouldn't say i had any crazy pop out
experiences like that
however i definitely had experiences
where i
knew hands down that i was
not this body i was not this mind that
this body is creating
an illusion of the reality we experience
and um the first time that was very
clear was during i did
the vipassana 10 days awesome yeah and
on on the eighth day i remember i was
just sitting and
you know you're feeling all the
sensations you're feeling into the body
and you're feeling all these waves
go through you and at one point i just
couldn't tell the difference of what was
inside and outside
i couldn't tell the difference of where
my body ended
i couldn't tell the difference between
sound and feeling
or like if there was wind or what i was
sitting on it was all
just vibration all of it was just
like like all of it was just vibration
and it was clear i was like our mind is
saying this vibration is sound
this vibration is touched
this is inside me this is outside me
but these are all mind labels and that
was the first time
it was just one field it was a field of
vibration
and it was so clear
so that was a very big transformational
moment as well
i would say and the other one was
maybe about four to five months ago i
was um
when was the ten day set that was a
while ago i'd say
maybe four years ago cool four years ago
yeah
and just about four months ago i had i
was meditating
and i was very
i was experiencing
i was in the space of space and then in
the space of
awareness watching
experiences come and go
and at one point
there was just this clarity that i am
eternal
yeah it was just i am eternal and it was
it was so funny it seemed so obvious but
it was
that i'm aware of i am aware of this
not i the body not either mind i
awareness i'm aware of everything that's
happening right now
yeah if this body dies i will just be
aware of what's happened
what else has happened it was
so it was just obvious it's like i will
be here regardless of what
is coming in and out of this experience
i am before this experience and if this
experience goes
i will still be here and that was
very very powerful it's so it was so
clear and so obvious it was how does
nobody see this but i mean coming out of
that experience
yes you you can see why it's it's it's
a subtlety
and um yeah and then after that i've
just been following bentino on
instagram i saw the no limit society and
immediately said i'm winning
all right no limits mentorship and said
no matter what
i'm going to be there i don't care and
it was weird because he asked you to
send a video in
and that's basically just what i said on
the video i said i
i'm not sure how long i can stay i'm not
sure
how long i can commit to it but i know i
want this so this resonates so strongly
and i know i have to be here right now
and yeah that's how i got involved and
then after the two months
i just had this he said no limit society
was emerging and i just had this
resonance
this pull to be part of no limit society
and i didn't know why because i mean
building this mentorship was so
good it was so amazing had so many
shifts there
but i felt this pull and like part of
his teachings is
follow the resonance right follow the
resonance
so that's what i did and i'm really
happy i did
because i feel a i've met
so many so many just beautiful people
and i've
been able to learn act like learn a ton
from the calls we're having and
secondly i feel as though
there's
there's some sort of co-creation in this
overall
vision and the society happening at the
same time which i i couldn't have been a
part of if i was
still a part of no limitless mentorship
okay i'm gonna plant a flag there
and we'll get back to what you just
wrapped with
so
beautiful share on the trajectory
on the awakening on the
recognizing the true nature
i found your share with
the swing into the
science the analysis of form
infinity and even
dabbles of atheism to be
fascinating because i've noticed that
many
of the greatest
spiritual minds that i know
are those that have swung the pendulum
the deepest into
the science and then have swung it into
the spiritual
and are now in a process of merging the
two
into one
and
i have a strong feeling that that's
mostly what the
21st century is going to be about
and i would also like to say that that
global enlightenment retreat was
world class and that
yeah and also
similarly as so patricia commented that
she had the same experience in vipassana
which is which is awesome and
i also had a similar experience in
vipassana
and that's probably one of the best
ways to use
one of the direct teachings of the
buddha
to calm the noisy mind
and as you do that you commune with the
true nature
and you can then add that into your
said sort of lattice work because
eckhart tolle will teach you
something that's you know another angle
up this
mountain right and so you add these
different paths
slash faces of the mountain to make a
really strong
lattice work around the true nature
and another thing that i was going to
say while you're speaking but i saved it
and i'd like to hear your thoughts on
this first and then we'll get to what
you wrapped with
is
would you say that the ground
or rigpa
in essence is emptiness
source and then infinite creation
it seems
it's not in my experience deep enough
for me
to say that with conviction but
what i can say
is that it's
clear that there is
a space within which everything happens
and are you that space
it seems so
it's hard you know because it's easy to
pair it back
things you hear and it's easy to
you know take what you hear from these
teachers like bentino
and sreenis
but i mean one thing i know a lot of
these
these um teachers they tell you is don't
believe anything
don't believe anything it's it's within
you to see it for yourself
and when you talk about this field of
vibration though
that was direct experience yes
yes but even that vibration
is within something more subtle
even that vibration is within a space
yeah but it has to be you
otherwise how
how would it be within your experience
otherwise
one of the core
[Music]
teachings of sadhara mishore
as you think so you are and so passing
that along to nisargatita
who has passed it along to many as well
is the holding
of said absolute
that very source of infinite possibility
and then sort of
as we've talked about with frank yang on
the show several times as well as like
okay it's intellectual
and then it becomes more and more
experiential and then it's like okay
well
what happens if i just like
sit and not do
anything
and that's when the ship becomes
realized
yeah yeah
sitting and not doing anything it's so
hard
[Laughter]
it's hard but you know what once you
once you realize the mind is just
fighting for its own survival
and you let it be there if you don't
identify with it it becomes
such a beautiful practice so beautiful
just grounded you feel unshakeable
unshakable
[Laughter]
yeah and then the polar opposite like
you just said
is the abiding and emptiness
and the unshakeability
it's so strong it's so strong when
you're in that space
you just feel like it's eternal
unshakable
whatever happens you're still here
anything that happens you're still here
i'm curious where your
hesitation comes from because
you seem
you seem quite
familiar with direct experience
and yet what is that which
feels the
potential of i am not good enough
to be able to say that i know
[Music]
it's funny i said i told you i went
through this big transformation
of needing validation and wanting to be
seen i think simultaneously
there's still a lingering
doubt distortion
it's fine it's paradoxical wanting to be
seen yet fear of being seen
right because with um as bentinius
talked about the
the more authentically
you are yourself
it comes with both sides of
being seen
and um it comes with the people the die
hards who resonate with everything you
say
and the opposite polarity of those who
really dislike what you say i don't know
if you saw it but on bentina's
instagram one day he wrote
he he screenshotted something someone
wrote on one of his comments
and someone had written i hope you rot
in a prison cell
and um he said even though he he doesn't
really identify with
it it's still to a certain extent
irks him when he's trying to show love
and support for the entire globe
he says something like that
you know and have you ever heard the
aphorism
it goes with the crown comes the
guillotine
i haven't no yeah
yep we take on
so much of
maximizing the potential of the
collective
and are very misunderstood
and very similarly if you were to
watch these
two dudes from you from seven years ago
watching us have this conversation
you'd be like what do they mean don't do
anything and sit in emptiness
yeah my atheist self would have been
like lazy
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and and that's the
paradigmatic shift
that is coming where
the resonance
of silence
becomes more
truly loved
right now there's no love for that empty
source
space when was the last time that you
just looked at
space that's one of my favorite
exercises
i love looking at space
every time i look at space i become
space
and it's just emptiness
and so you think it's like
out of the 16 hours of
waking perception that people have
daily 8 billion
right so it's
somewhere around
let's say uh 128
billion waking hours
of human perception daily
what what percentage
of that is
passed in empty
silence abiding
in freedom and perfection
that we already are
and my estimate would be it's less than
one percent
i agree and that's the shift in 2020
2030
is a shift to one percent two percent
three percent popularizing it more
and more to where people recognize that
wow how is it possible that
if you gather for example you were just
on a
camping trip
right and we gather people in our
living room let's say in our houses or
whatnot
and typically what happens is you gather
three five
seven people whatnot and everyone talks
talk talk talk talk talk talk talk talk
all night long talk
talk talk talk talk talk talk talk talk
oh there's some space you need to fill
it with talking
and what you learn is that
sometimes when you're around
really subtle awakened people and nobody
talks and you just abide in silence
together
that there's actually more
awakening that is catalyzed
through silence than there is through
talking
absolutely
absolutely i think it was alan watts he
was talking about
how something to do with the human
condition and
we think and the only thing we think
about are thoughts
and then we think more about thoughts
and we have other thoughts about those
thoughts
so where where's the space for learning
where's the space for growth
you're having the same thoughts over and
over and over again and
thinking about those thoughts
and
yeah just what you said about the
silence
even going back to doing like we were
talking about
you have to do something
but the person you think is doing
something
doesn't even exist
so who is it that's doing something and
i think bentino he was saying
on the uh might have been called number
two
or three the physical
is the crystallization of the vibration
it is the
end result how can you do
something from the end result
it's the end right
all doing is an unfolding of
the vibrational state
perfect
so focusing on that vibration
is
integral
this has been
talked about for a while
which is that
as we navigate
our way back inward with that
absolute gps callback
and we hit this
ineffable changeless
nature
beyond all coming and going
we
there is this very effortless action
that arises as is said in
rikpa in the very spontaneous
presence and creativity unfolding
now that
depending on the skill
will be a specific
caliber let's say of bodhisattva
for example if one spent 20 years in
understanding
science and engineering and
entrepreneurship and art
it is easier for them to
be a architect of the protocols
that enable the meeting of the
sustainable development goals whereas
if somebody lands at said
ineffable changeless
that does not have that experience
then there's a different style of
bodhisattva and so
every single time that one of the
planetary basic needs is met
we have to also remember that that is
what also
enables people to investigate the
changeless
[Music]
because ain't nobody got time
to go
inward when it's bouncing between
two 40-hour per week jobs
to feed three kids absolutely
and so what will happen when we create
that
universal basic stakeholding
infrastructure
where people actually have
their basic needs being met so that they
can
embark on these virtual reality
pedagogies
that sort of take them through an
investigation of
who am i what is i what
is me and go through this style of like
vr ar mixed reality style pedagogy of
this
journey inward that then leads them to
the recognition and then that makes them
more
of a pure
shepherd or steward for the
awakening so i always like to
i always like to say that there is
simultaneously
these little like asterisks along
that way which is that that the
protocols
when you have your needs being met
enables
more of the investigation and word and
also depending on what you learned
prior to uniting enables you
as a bodhisattva
i'm curious as to what you think of
cases like eckhart tolle's awakening
do you know his story
i'm not sure if he shared it in the
power of now
it was in one of the two books i forget
which one
but basically long story short he was in
a suicidal state
he had no prior seeking in this life at
least there was no prior seeking
there was no distilling
no no shadow work he
was suicidal he was ready to kill
himself he was in a suicidal state
and he had this thought that was i can't
live with myself
and then he started thinking about that
thought
i can't live with myself who is the i
that the self cannot live with and then
he realized there was
there was a separation being created
in the mind the i and the self
that is separate to the eye and he had
went into an immediate vortex
and he woke up his entire perspective
everything had changed
he had no idea what happened to him
absolutely no idea what happened to him
but he just said i started noticing the
sunlight
picked up a pencil it was beautiful
i went and sat in a park bench basically
like no home
in pure bliss for days and it was only
after a little while later when he was
searching that he found out what had
happened to him
so i'm like i'm curious if you have any
thoughts on stories like that where it's
just
instantaneous
this is the beauty of intelligent
infinity
is that you'll never come to the end of
all possibility
and so you'll get these awakenings that
happen on the spectrum of
decades and decades and decades and
decades
and then you'll get these awakenings
that are sudden so the gradual and
sudden
are two poles and that people
have been flowed between them people get
pops
people sometimes have no idea what
happens for days
and then they're like how do i get back
to that what was that
and all this type of stuff and it's
fascinating and
over time we'll end up
documenting more
of people's unique experiences with
satori
on the program and then be sharing that
and making it streamlined in the media
how cool would it be to have literally
you know a channel
that only featured people talking about
their satori
amazing perfect amazing
and right now we have two polls
of in the united states at least it's
very
liberal versus conservative propaganda
and it has absolutely nothing
to do with enlightenment or awakening
and the investigation inward and so
now imagine what it would look like if
you had
a poll that was like
featuring people awakening gradually and
then another one that was featuring
people awakening suddenly and they were
kind of like bickering a little bit and
showcasing examples
i mean that would be cool i too wanted
that [ __ ] every night
yeah but you know what it's beautiful
that there are channels like yours
you know there's like gaia now which is
i mean
which is a netflix for i wouldn't say i
don't know about everything on it but
i've watched
a few things and they're beautiful
there's a couple of really a lot of
really cool content
things you are doing um you know like
um richard condon stuff bentino stuff
there's
there's all these beautiful pockets
emerging
and even oprah had eckhart she had
eckhart tolleon and she did a whole book
club with him which was really cool
yeah it's really clear that the
awakening is entering into the media
space
via all these nodes that you just listed
in it's awesome
two things that we should cover
one of them is what you wrapped
with about 20 or 30 minutes ago you were
talking about
the unnuanced
difference in nlm and nls
can you share slash unpack that at
however much you feel comfortable with
for sure
as you know there's only so much we can
share because of our ndas
it's funny when i first joined came into
nls from nlm
it seemed a little scattered to me but
now in retrospect it was the same when
we
on the first month of nlm and
both were i feel actually now that i'm
thinking about very fortunate to be
part of the beginning of both programs
so um just to see how you know things
progressed
one of the subtleties i would say is
bentino's presence in the family chat
makes a very big difference the energy
the space
the direction he brings it
it's just like this north star you know
if there's any
topics that are
i don't want to say misunderstood but if
there's
certain discussions between topics or
there's a certain
you know two people are
quote unquote bickering about about a
certain topic
spentino can step in and kind of give
his his
more give his guidance from
uh from a clearer perspective from a
clear perspective
and it makes a big difference in the
evolution
of
everybody everybody
that that is and also he
has this he's the leader he has a
leadership role he has a leadership
presence
in nls we're all peers
so there's this room for you know if
bentino says something
everyone's kind of like okay cool this
makes sense
and if um i'm not
i'm not uh like any different from what
i'm about to say but like
there are reflections pointed out and
our own distortions come through with
that as well
right it's not it's not always clear
it's not always
coming from the clearest place even if
it's
uh unconscious
so that i would say is kind of the
the difference is the biggest kind of
differences and also the fact that it's
90 people versus
23 people yeah
right and but that being said in the
last
week or two the energy shift in nls has
been
huge huge it's beautiful
it's beautiful like i said this leader
stepping up there's people providing
structure
that there's you started a meditation
call
and yeah there's just the energy shift
has been and i think it's just because
you know
you start a new group everyone's trying
to like find their place there's all
these personalities
um that think they need to like
fulfill their own personal desires
but once it all kind of settles in and
everyone is on the same page it's
the energy shift it's so nice now
it's really nice it's a lot quieter and
it's a lot more intentional
it's a lot more service to others i
would say
as opposed to i think a lot of shares
earlier
were
it wasn't even shares i think there was
a lot of intention
before and just connecting and just
excited to be around
other people who are in who are on the
same path
but now it's settled more into a
purification intention
beautiful great share
i also feel like oola's
recommendation with accountability
partners
ended up clearing out a lot of the nls
chat because now we do it with our
partners
a lot of the work which is super
interesting
absolutely and i think uh nathan was it
nathan who shared uh
the structure the document the structure
he shared a document that gave structure
to the the
accountability partners which was
was that mark and sonia oh maybe oh
you're right
yeah yes cool cool
yep yep and that's been huge
i feel like this is the general
trajectory
of groups like you indicated is that
if you look at another
click let's say bezos and the
executives at amazon there's a small
group of the c-level execs
that continuously discuss
amazon's trajectory
and then there's a group of maybe a
hundred of the
vice presidents
and they're in another group where bezos
doesn't pop in as much
or whatever just to give an analogy
and that the vps in the group of a
hundred
maybe at first
are a little bit
a like prove myself in this way or that
way
and then over time it's kind of more of
a
maybe more of a little bit of a relaxing
a little bit more of a
it's there's a divine unfolding aspect
to this
and this is a juxtaposition that does no
longer really holds because in the
business sphere
there's there's no oh there's not much
awakened
in the business sphere so there's
there's no sort of
relaxing into the divine perfection that
it is there's a perpetual
i will do because of the watch
because i think that the material
possession is going to
make me happy
but so in the case of what's happening
in nls
it does really feel like there's a sort
of a natural
both relaxation into the surrender
divine unfolding
of what's happening along with that
bit of beautiful structure like what you
were saying
with maybe oola coming in and saying hey
accountability partners what do you guys
think or like
hey guys what about these you know these
nls
i would say that one of the components
that's most
successful in the group right now
is when bentino gives an assignment
or when we say that hey let's take one
of those
video calls from the no limits
mentorship all watch it
and then have a conversation about it in
a sense
this very like intention-driven
and i think that's has a lot to do with
what you were saying about
the intention-drivenness of it and also
the purification
drivenness of it because now there's
like
the in a sense it feels like the navy
seals aspect to it is kicking in
a little bit more which is which is in a
sense what
i'm i'm most excited about yes
i love it when there's other navy seals
that are like yo there's a call on
saturday about some of the
profound bits in one of the nlm
videos and it's like yep that's a
homework assignment you know i'm on it
you know i'm on it because like i know
what that's gonna
provide for the further purification
and the
purification of where we're coming from
in service
etc so this is probably one of my
favorite
conversations that i've had with another
nls
member because we're doing it really
surgically and really precisely while
maintaining
this sacredness of the nda and whatnot
and i think that
it's also cool to have this with you
because
you came in a month before me i've been
in for about a month now
and that
we are now having a conversation about
the structure which
will in a sense be a cool way for
people that are entering in to
further which is what nlm did nlm
did this process and we recently saw
that
sort of get replied to a little bit ago
where it was beautiful watching as they
created some sort of a
how do we keep our living room clean was
one of the small ways to think about it
right how do we keep our living room
clean is one of the ways to think about
it so
there's a lot of fascinating aspects to
group dynamics like this that
i feel like are going to be critical as
more of the awakening picks up
yes yes i agree um
yeah i think one of like
you nailed it by saying the in the
intention has shifted a lot and
it's it doesn't seem
as though
the shares seem very intentional and
service to others it's not
sharing to look at me
it's not sharing to be seen it's sharing
with
intention to to provide to support
to illuminate
there was a share recently i believe it
was by nada
and um i watched it today and she shared
it a few weeks ago and
it was it really helped me refine
my calling today and you actually shared
a video with richard
conden yeah i saw you reply to that yeah
cool yeah yeah
so yeah like i said it's really it's
really great to see the shift
that nls is in right now and i know the
team um
they have uh they're still ventino on
the team they're still doing a lot of
refinement and there's a lot of ideas
coming up and
so yeah it should be it should be
exciting to see where it goes
because i'm just going to say because
bentino
his his calling is to ignite
global awakening and he really sees both
of these as
as tools towards that as this yes
yep and the callings
that are shining in
nls are all
part of this mission and the mission is
very
beautifully both centralized and
decentralized which is really
fascinating
and it's
it's sacred there's just no other way to
speak about it it's just sacred
and we're grateful beyond words that
we're here
and
it's unbelievable this guidance that has
been happening
there's that little meme where it's like
the higher self is
is is pushing the you
it's like you're in the little cart and
the higher self is pushing you down
there
it's so fun it's so funny
and and like there's like just so much
gratitude for
landing in this spiritual navy seals
container
and the
we were messaging about this like a week
or two ago where we were just reflecting
on just
how just yummy it's just it tastes
delicious it feels really good on the
nervous system
this intention-driven purification
driven awakening driven navy seals-esque
style of approach which
i can't find anywhere else i yeah it's
just it's
not as
cleanly reflecting
impurities and ascending and awakening
and weaving realizations into
the fabric i really liked
what bentino and team reflected to me
in costa rica which was something along
the lines of
you're not ready
and it was really important because
they had this analogy which is
your need to force
your perspective is what's going to
create holes in the ship
so until you can relax
your perspective and hold
the view of the absolute
from a completely pure place
with the intention of just
transparent purification
you can't be yet
ready which is why it looks like the nlm
is slowly becoming ready
and and so for those that don't know
there's like a no limits
mentorship layer up here that's closest
to like continuo in the existing team
and then there's the no limit society
which is sort of this
next level layer which is
there's about a hundred people in this
one and then there's about 23
as mesh said in the no limits mentorship
one which is where bentino is kind of
directly coming in and chatting and
they're keeping the living room more
clean and now this seems like this
living room is being kept more clean
of the nls which is great
yep so blessed beyond words
it's amazing it's like you said the
i don't i haven't found anything else
that similar to this because there
are a lot of spiritual communities
at least from the ones i've experienced
or at least
ones i've yeah the ones i've experienced
are more that
fourth density like
love you know murdered him and stuff
like that
so this is just uh it's just coming i
feel like from a
cleaner a cleaner space
yep
i would say the general zeitgeist of
the fourth density
heart chakra opening community which is
the vast majority of spiritual community
is the inability to balance with wisdom
and that's why the law of one density
ascent
resonates so deeply with us is because
that is really the core
aspect to what's wrong in a sense
with that overly
zealous love martyrdom
and that's why people go and
relentlessly overzealously need to
awaken their family
and their friends and that
the jokes are endless the endless
shadow work the endless trauma work the
endless tree hugging and tree planting
and
um and
you never even get an understanding of
what it's like to be a mirror
you never get to that understanding and
that's a shame
because there's nothing as beautiful as
being so
empty that you get to hold
space for the pure
service to the awakening
of the creation through that process
because it's so needed right now
for people to be awakened enough and
open enough and empty enough like that
to cr provide
those reflections to those that are most
which is what you could say happened
to me as i described to you my
experience
by the team getting that style of
reflection
and only those truly
willing to receive said reflection
and not run away it's easy to get it and
be like
this community telling me what you think
about you
and then run away because you know you
got hijacked by the conditioning
to run away and now you go to somewhere
more comfortable
do the navy seals run away to what's
more comfortable
no and so yep
yeah that um it's so easy to avoid
discomfort and suffering and do
everything
in your power to not feel
it's so easy and um
i mean i've i was talking with somebody
recently
who was saying
it's almost like they're
trying to use spiritual concepts
to avoid it so it's like
in in in a way saying i'm just
meditating so i don't suffer
i'm meditating so i don't suffer so i
was like what what's wrong with
suffering
what's wrong with suffering if it's
coming up why
why are you avoiding it and she's like
well i just want to be in my power
i just want to be in my power
great so isn't the most powerful thing
you can do
to let what comes up come up isn't that
true power so
yeah there's this distortion of
spiritual concepts that are actually
hurting the awakening process
and again i think that comes from this
fourth density heavy
uh emphasis
precisely and i would like to
wrap with asking you about
your calling being about joy
and clarity
and what that
means to you and what
you've felt
that you would like to create
as experiences for people to feel
even with identifying my calling today
this morning
i was really refined into joy and
clarity when i watched that video shared
by nada
it was very elusive for me for a long
time
ever since i was young i knew
i was kind of like whenever i saw my mom
upset i would
go give her a tissue or like if i saw
someone hurting i would go talk with
them and sit with them ask them what's
wrong
and i think this so i
initially thought my calling had to do
with funny because what we just talked
about
but i thought my um
calling had to do with helping
people get rid of their suffering
but in analem it became abundantly clear
through many reflections to me that i
wanted to stop people from suffering
because i was uncomfortable with
suffering
and suffering plays a very key role in
your awakening process and one of my
favorite quotes by mentino
is um are you
it's i'm paraphrasing but it's something
along the lines of
are you so arrogant to think you know
better than their higher self and i
love that
i love it so
this was like back to square one for me
what do i want to do
how do i want to affect people and
obviously it was around service to
others
and just listening to
robert uh sorry richard condon today
he was saying what kind of world do you
want to live in
what kind of world do you want to create
and just listening to him i was
just trying to sit in the space what
really resonates for me what really
resonates
and i think the flip of
getting rid of people suffering i don't
want to get rid of their suffering
but i do i get i love it when i see
people just in in a joyful blissful
state
it's so beautiful because you know
that they're not like in pert they're
not a person
in that moment in that joyful state
it's not a person anymore it's just pure
connection it's pure
like vibration and bliss and it's not
it's such an expansive feeling
so that's the joy that's the joy like
when you see somebody do something
selfless for somebody else
and they you see the joy they get from
from it's just such an expansive feeling
beautiful and
the clarity i think the clarity is the
other thing
um when i mean clarity i mean
[Music]
helping people or it doesn't even have
to be me helping people it's just when
people
see
if there was something in someone's
experience that was contracting
contract what contracted for them
understanding that that is false
you're identified you're contracting
because you're identifying with
something false
and then when they have
the clarity to see when they actually
have the moment of clarity
oh my god that was false
holy cow what a beautiful thing that is
ah these are great um
just to share an experience where that
happened to me was i was meditating
this was recently i think i shared it
i'm not sure if you were on the group at
this point but
i shared it in nls i was meditating
and i was sitting in the space causal
body
and i was trying to who's aware of the
who's aware of the space who's aware of
the space so i'm
i'm trying to get into this space and
all these little
my mind just keeps popping up with this
my mind keeps popping up with that and
my mind keeps chopping up with this and
i started to get frustrated and i and
then i noticed
that this judgment and all this little
judgments come up
saying you've been meditating for so
long
why are you still struggling with this
you've been meditating for so long why
are you focusing on this
and then i noticed the judgment and then
i became aware of the judgment
and i had this beautiful moment of
clarity
where i have never judged myself
a thought of judgment arises and i
choose to identify with the thought of
judgment
but i have never
judged myself
and that moment of clarity it was
huge huge
because that's god that's how god sees
you
yes yeah cool
so if i could help people to have these
same types of realizations
to see themselves the way god sees them
to know there's nothing to be scared of
that's where that's the kind of work i
want to do how does it look like
i'm not sure yet but we'll let it unfold
you just want to give you hugs love it
love it
have you talked with v about joy
no could be interesting for you guys to
talk about
joy because you talk about joy from a
really
high understanding
of it and he does as well and
i would say that that taste that you
described
um he also describes
and so that's why and yeah
and the cl yeah that would be a good
idea and then the
clarity also
it
it really is the cessation of the
arguing
with god
and all of the clarity comes from the
turn inward and the cessation of the
arguing
and the clarity and just
with my calling with people experiencing
truth one of the most simple ways
that people can do that is like you
describe with this
point of deep clarity that they feel
when they see that
oh [ __ ]
i'm aware of awareness i'm aware of
being i'm aware of i
am i'm aware of i exist i'm finally
becoming
more aware of that and less
focused on objects
substances relationships experiences
that will make me happy
so that shift inward then
also as they unite with that clarity
they see
everything as one intelligence at play
with itself
and then even the identity
of the person dissolves
and this is a sort of a big
transformational moment of clarity
because the
taking on the universe as
your as frank yang says cosmic octopus
so now you've become the cosmic octopus
having
endless sex and play with itself
and then
you really are like okay
like mesh is a
tentacle and i'm a tentacle and there's
seven point
nine nine nine nine nine nine billion
other tentacles and
yeah and there's all the other like
sentient species on the planet
and there's just a lot of
you know dogs and cats are trying to
become humans and
there's like so much stuff there's
higher selves in the equation
and and you you really become
humble enough to stop being
arrogant and to stop arguing and you get
more clarity
i love the tentacles
frank and i will be doing some work in
the visualization of that
and we're really looking forward to
making that more mainstream because it
does feel like these visualizations
of these sort of centerless non-dual
even the very no self
that this
has a a
large propensity to
ignite awakening because
so many are very visual
you already are the universe
you are the source of the universe you
are this
creation but you the contracted identity
that's all it's all game of identity
just relax that contracted identity and
you'll get the joy and the clarity and
you'll get to
weave the realizations in
to society by being a steward a
shepherd by being empty and holding that
mirror like space
and there's just
it's uh it's so rich
everywhere you look to see the one
intelligence
it's so rich and then
yeah and then it all makes sense
it all clicks because you've went all
the way in
to realize that you are that which
manifested
this at play with itself
in terms of what you said about
visualization
for me one of the i love
um bentino's video game analogy
because um i play a lot of video games
and um
it's it's it's so good because
right now let's say you're playing like
grand theft auto or something
you're in this world you're controlling
this character
but you're believing you're the
character
you're believing you're the character
except everything in
that world is an expression of one thing
it's
all pixels or it's all ones and zeros
that character does not
exist you the higher you the person
the higher self is controlling or
guiding
this character but as soon as you begin
to believe you're that character
then you've lost uh
you you've become you're behind that
veil
you're behind that veil of forgetfulness
right and it's as if the character
is the character in the video game
it doesn't really do anything
it doesn't do anything it's guided by
you
it's guided by the controllers guided by
the user and i love
i love that analogy because it's so apt
to for a visual representation yeah
it is
a higher self component with the video
game character
is really strong there and also the
game console as source
itself and then the different games
being the creations yes yes
infinite games infinite
characters yeah that's why it's also
been called the eternal stage
and you appear and disappear and yeah
appear and disappear but will you
learn to identify yourself as that which
does not appear and disappear
as that which is the source of it
as that which is beyond coming and going
and so this is the shift in
identity shift your identity but
along with shifting your identity we've
learned that you
know love and accept yourself
because god already does perfect
perfect
i love what bentino shared today on the
mentorship about
quantum acceptance did you get a chance
to read that
it was one of the last messages but he
talked about
in i think either the costa rica retreat
or the one he's doing now
the new term that came up was that came
out of him
was a quantum acceptance where there's
acceptance where
you're trying to accept all these
different things
content acceptance is understanding that
everything is already accepted by god
nothing is rejected
perfect i see it perfect already
except yes yeah that was so beautiful
it was such a cool term
i understand that everything is already
accepted see the entire
creation at play with itself as
already fully accepted by the very
source that manifested the creation to
play with itself
yes it's only
our noisy mind that says
that i cannot accept
so distance yourself from that noisy
mind through the breath
there's many good practices to relax
into just being
into just awareness
just i am i
exist
not trying to get anything out of it
hmm that's another great one yep
full radical acceptance
and not needing to extract anything
these are the types of things that
people will get access to
by joining the no limits society which
we've been putting in the links
in the bio of our conversations
with members yeah so do
if this resonates with you just check
out the link in the bio below
going to read what continue and the team
wrote about the no limit society they
really meticulously wrote about it so
that
those that are truly adept ready for
this
can gain access to these
insights that we're talking about right
now
[Music]
it's such a powerful space it is such a
powerful space
i can tell you i've been doing self-help
work for
at least a decade and
lots of great insights absolutely
but nothing is transformational
nothing let's say
we get we got to think like when we're
18 we're not really ready
at when we where we were at to take on
in a sense the information in the change
in identity the shift
to seeing everything as
the creator at play with itself already
radically
being perfect and accepting it the way
it is and
now albeit there are i know 18 year olds
now
that know this which is amazing in the
awakening
but this is why we've went through this
so-called 10-year process of
yes becoming ready we
prepared ourselves yes
yes but also ran amuck
yeah not very direct yeah
but also somewhat direct yeah yeah
yeah i mean a lot of my self-help stuff
was ego based it had nothing to do with
self-realization
it was just how do you be more efficient
how do you make your memory better how
do you get stronger faster
you know like that's what i was learning
i was learning
from ceos like you know don't not like
don't sleep but like you want to be
working 80 hour weeks if you want to be
successful
that's the content i was consuming when
i was my atheist
[Laughter]
kind of period and even when i was into
self-realization i was still
consuming a lot of that stuff because i
didn't know this concept
of unfull uh the doing unfolding out of
the vibration
yes and what was my vibration at that
point it was terrible it's i want to be
something which means conversely that i
am not something
so yeah it's just
raising your vibration let it unfold
the roots the roots focus on the roots
yup
and where where are the roots they're
right next to the
they're the horizon of the black hole
the roots of the horizon to the black
hole
yes
nourish repeatedly without any
expectation
and then we unfold from that vibrational
state
wow there's so many good ones there's
that one
who's aware of the space abiding in
emptiness
unshakable eternal versus mind we gotta
do some [ __ ] bro
i'm the eternal source space of all
possibility
this one from the beginning to what
extent are my actions trying to please
the child
versus being pure service to others
understand what the catalyst is trying
to show you
where am i coming from to what extent am
i coming from
needing to be seen
amazing show together mesh thank you
thank you so much for having me it was
such a blast and
i love what you're doing here i love i
love what you're doing here
it's so beautiful
that's so great
it's an honor and i've shared this with
v
is that the guests that come on the show
have a unique aroma they have a unique
taste of union
and so we get to share that and
with the audience and in the process we
get to capture a cool piece of content
and we and we get to do this tennis
style dialectic
creation talking to itself and as that
happens
guess what the soul attunement
also gets stronger and so
i the atlas soul gets to learn
a lot from these processes and then
the guests also do and
that's also really fun is when the guest
is like this created a forcing function
for me to share and in the sharing
process
i ended up learning about how to say
something a way that i previously hadn't
thought of before
or whatnot absolutely you're
our mini conversation yesterday over
text where
you just briefly said yeah we're just
going to let it flow and
talk about that and you i think in
passing you mentioned calling and i was
like man
i'm not 100 sure on my calling like it's
still
not um it's
i knew what it was surrounding but it
wasn't
articulated clearly enough and
because this triggered me to go deep
into that uh richard video today
and it was beautiful and i thank you for
that because i was on cloud nine this
morning when i recognized what it was
i was on cloud nine and it was because
you know when you identify it you
you identify it by the feeling of
expansiveness that you get
from it and i was just like this is it
this is it
and the second
just most delicious
feeling which is embedded within this
first for me around the calling of
people experiencing truth
is people unleashing
their callings right
that's such a critical part of this
and so the creation
wants itself to unleash
its callings by all of the turns
inward in the stopping of the arguing
and it came also because nada put the
content in
and all of these components that lined
up
doop doop doop and then it was like
unluck yay totally yeah
that's such a beautiful creation
that was a really good one the quantum
acceptance
that's a really good one
full radical devotional
surrendered acceptance that you
as a person do not know as
much as the very source
of it all already radically
loves and accepts it all so
relax the [ __ ] out of that contracted
ass
selfish ass perspective
i love that i love that a lot it's like
going all the way in
to the very emptiness itself
and then realizing that the emptiness
already
fully accepts its infinite creation
perfect
one of arrogant quotes i love is are you
so arrogant to think
that you're the only thing that's not
accepted in this world
yep
boom just so strong i'm so grateful
definitely one of my favorite
nls convos we've had on the programs
just on fire
mesh so good i honestly appreciate you
having me here i got so much out of it
and i'm sure your audience will
get out a lot out of everything you're
doing here and i hope it grows man i
hope it grows to infinity
and everyone who needs to see this sees
this
yeah we have a
a beautiful array especially recently in
the last
month of very
high level awakened tennis players that
have come on and have blossomed and so
especially this last month highly
recommend people to
go back and listen to the conversations
and
take some notes reflect on what's been
shared
and especially
i'm just saying stuff like this
[Laughter]
i think everybody can relate to this
even if you don't know what the
stillness is you can like kind of relate
to it yeah
yeah yeah
hell yeah and let's see where should we
um where should we recommend people to
can people follow you somewhere
[Music]
instagram youtube anything instagram's
fine
i've been kind of inactive on it it's
mostly for my music stuff but it's not
kind of surrounding this content
um yeah you can instagram
instagram is fine i'm sure i'm sure i
will now that my calling is more clear
i will be
sharing more content in relation to that
clarity enjoy
awesome we'll have the link in the bio
below to yeah give mesh a follow
and let us know
i just want to say even if someone just
wants to have a conversation feel free
to
i'm like i can have jump on a call like
any time i love having conversations if
anybody just wants to talk
or discuss anything i can offer any
insight i do have and i would love to
would love to
thank you so nice excellent so message
in for
convo and let us know
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode thank you everyone for
tuning in
love to hear from you about what
resonated and
also to share it with other people that
you feel like this would resonate with
like the video if it brought you value
helps the algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet
and infinite love
that was fire perfect thank you atlas
thank you mash thank you thank you
everyone
cool i'll end the broadcast we'll stay
in the studio thanks everyone much love
much love
you